[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
annie genevard bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député du
doubs présidente du conseil national des
républicains
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale
représentait ce matin par fabrice
desserts dont du groupe ebra pour
février sont en vie le groupe et bradley
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
annie genevard le gouvernement a donc
annoncé hier des mesures en faveur de
l'emploi de l'emploi des jeunes et
notamment de l'apprentissage avec des
aides pour les entreprises qui
embauchent des apprentis on ne veut pas
de génération sacrifiée c'est ce que dit
muriel pénicaud est-ce que vous soutenez
ces mesures oui bien sûr il est est
indispensable de prendre une initiative
en faveur de l'apprentissage
nous sommes très inquiets de plusieurs
choses concernant la jeune génération
d'abord tous ces jeunes qui vont arriver
sur le marché de l'emploi
ils sont prêts ce camillo et ces jeunes
n'arrive évidemment pas au meilleur
moment
un moment où l'emploi se fait rare où
les entreprises sont fragiles
nous non pas de claire vision de leur
avenir donc nous sommes très inquiet
pour les jeunes pour l'emploi des jeunes
qui arrivent sur le marché du travail et
nous sommes très inquiet aussi pour les
jeunes qui était et qui se destinait à
l'apprentissage parce que pour
accueillir un apprenti il faut avoir de
la disponibilité faut avoir un peu de
moyens c'est pareil il faut être en
disposition d'accueillir des jeunes en
apprentissage et il fallait absolument
prendre une initiative pour encourager
les entreprises et là je crois que cette
mesure le permettra
c'est c'est une mesure que nous
appelions nous veut et que nous
soutenons sans réserve
vous avez d'ailleurs présenté cette
semaine avec christian jacob damien abad
également le plan plan de relance oui un
du côté des républicains
on a le sentiment quand même que la
droite des républicains a une fibre un
peu plus social dans ce dans cette
période de crise c'est quelque chose qui
va durer ou c'est ponctuel
alors si vous regardez l'histoire même
récente l'histoire de notre mouvement
c'est faux de dire que les
préoccupations sociales ont été absentes
de notre famille politique
vous avez des grandes figures qui ont
incarné je dirais la la fibre sociale de
notre famille politique à commencer par
le père fondateur charles de gaulle la
participation
c'est cette idée elle naît avec avec le
gaullisme
ce gain est une grande figure sociale du
gaullisme et des républicains donc là
congrès pendant ce temps pendant cette
période dans cette période il est normal
aux yeux de la droite que l'état fasse
du social il est normal dans cette
période mais même en dehors de cette
période de chercher la corrélation la
bonne combinaison entre une ligne
libérale que nous assumons et que nous
continuons d'assumer nous ne sommes pas
favorables à une économie administrée on
voit ce qu'elle a donné à peu près
partout dans le monde
donc nous sommes favorables à un
libéralisme mais le libéralisme ça ne
veut pas dire la surdité aux questions
sociales tout au contraire un
libéralisme assumé et un libéralisme qui
réussit c'est quelqu'un qui fait toute
sa place à l'humain justement on va
continuer sur ces questions d'emploi
autres annoncé hier mais réelle pénicaud
qui dit que les discussions vont
s'ouvrir pour
la réforme de l'assurance chômage les
discussions s'ouvrent des décisions
seront prises avant l'été est ce que
pour vous il faut modifier cette réforme
voire la supprimer
alors il est clair que la crise
sanitaire à nous oblige à reconfigurer
un peu tous nos logiciels si je puis
dire et je pense que en matière d'emploi
parce que ça va être la priorité c'est
déjà la priorité et ça sera d'ailleurs
l'objet du plan de finances qui va être
présenté au parlement on va parler c'est
l'emploi c'est l'emploi il faut soutenir
les secteurs pourvoyeurs d'emplois donc
revoir cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage alors sans doute revisiter cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage
et puis redire à quel point il est
important que le dialogue s'établissent
au sein de l'entreprise
le débat qui est acquis qui agite en ce
moment les les questions sociales sur la
diminution de salaires sur
l'augmentation du temps de travail
toutes ces questions là ne peuvent se
résoudre que dans un dialogue social
bien compris au sein de l'entreprise est
ce qu est ce que vous vous les comprenez
ces entreprises qui demandent à leurs
salariés de baisser leur salaire pour
soutenir pour sauver leurs emplois
alors c'est une c'est une demande
difficile douloureuse d'autant que pas
mal de salariés ont perdu du pouvoir
d'achat avec la crise sanitaire
même si le chômage partiel à compenser
on sait aussi que les salaires sont
faibles en france donc proposé de
baisser les salaires ça n'est pas rien
et on ne peut pas soutenir par principe
un mouvement qui viserait à baisser les
salaires alors alors que l'on sait qu'en
france ils sont déjà trop beau dit si ce
n est pas ça me l'entreprise établit un
dialogue avec les salariés et juge temps
semblé qu'il juste ensemble que c'est
une nécessité temporaire
donc c'est oui sur la base du dialogue
social alors ça ne peut se faire que sur
la base du dialogue social je ne vois
pas comment ça peut être décrété
autrement on va parler à un mode renault
et l'état qui a donc validé le prêt de 5
milliards après avoir obtenu des
assurances notamment sur l'avenir du
site de maubeuge est ce que pour vous
ces assurances sont suffisantes ou il ce
qu'il fallait demander plus de garanties
plus de contreparties vous savez les
garanties elles valent le temps qu'on
les donne
on se rappelle de general electric
des milliers d'emplois des centaines
d'emplois promis donc
renault a abordé cette crise fragile en
état de fragilité et
ce que ce qui était à craindre ces
produits c'est à dire que la crise a
joué un rôle d'accélérateur clairement
renault est engagé dans une lutte pour
sa survie
donc vous venez du doubs le berceau de
psa un des voitures ils jouaient ce que
vous êtes inquiet sur l'avenir de cette
filière est une région qui a beaucoup de
sous traitance automobile
oui oui nous on est on est inquiet parce
que la sous traitance qui est très
importante comme vous le dites dans
notre région a été complètement à
l'arrêt moi dans ma ville j'ai une
entreprise de sous traitance automobile
250 salariés 25 salariés sur le site
pendant le confinement donc et plus
d'activité mais l'activité reprend et le
psa n'est pas du tout dans la même
situation que nous cela dit il ne faut
pas se décourager parce que je me
souviens très bien qu'il ya quelques
années dans un avenir relativement
récent psa a été dans une situation
difficile
ils ont eu des orientations intelligente
et aujourd'hui psa se porte bien donc
moi je suis confiante l'activité va
reprendre
mais la clé et chez le consommateur
retrouvera-t-il la confiance l'économie
c'est de la confiance
vous allez d'abord de la confiance vous
allez voter ce plan alors jusqu'à
présent nous avons toujours voter les
projets de loi de finances rectificative
et les mesures de soutien
parce que nous considérons qu'il faut
sauver prioritairement les emplois les
entreprises
donc nous avons voté l'état d'urgence
sanitaire nous avons voté les plfr je
pense que nous voterons celui ci qui a
vocation à soutenir des filières très en
difficulté comme le tourisme
l'aéronautique ou l'automobile
donc voilà il faut qu'on voit ce qu'il
ya dedans je peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui oui il est certain que c'est
probable c'est probable parce que toutes
ces filières qui sont très très
pourvoyeuses d'emplois sont très en
difficulté le tourisme est un secteur
qui nous
créé et qui nous fait beaucoup de souci
parce que on comprend on comprend que
vous êtes vous avez dans l'idée
d'accompagner ce dispositif se planque
qui est présenté par le gouvernement
vous pensez que jusqu'à présent ce qui
est fait par gouvernement va dans le bon
sens je dirais qu'il fallait faire et
donc il fallait le soutenir mais ce que
je déplore c'est que on a dû mettre le
pays à l'arrêt total c'est quoi c'est le
confinement que vous remettez en cause
je parle ce qu'assure le gouvernement a
été obligé de confiner drastiquement le
pays parce qu'il n'avait pas d'autre
moyen de protéger les français
vous pensez à quoi s'était confinement
je pense au mas carbasse parents sous
respirateur je pense aux lits d'hôpitaux
je pense au gel hydroalcoolique je pense
au défaut d'anticipation
la situation était difficile chacun en
convient et
il il faut être il faut être modeste
néanmoins il y avait quand même des
signes avant coureurs très très
préoccupant et puis surtout la
précédente épidémie avait instruit le
gouvernement de l'époque et avait dans
un plan pandémie prévu des stocks de
masques régulièrement renouvelables la
commande de respirateurs des procédures
et tout ça s'est évaporé dans le temps
donc votre préconisations pour l'avenir
j'imagine qu'ils essaient de tirer les
enseignements mais c'est tirer les
enseignements pour éviter de mettre le
pays à l'arrêt parce qu'aujourd'hui on
est à genoux on voit bien l'économie est
à genoux
le nombre de chômeurs à un chômage
partiel c'est quelque chose de demandes
de dîner dit jamais vu mais c'est
surtout les chômeurs qui vont en
résulter de ce chômage partiel
donc on a dû confiner le coup d'arrêt a
été trop brutale
et il a été trop brutale parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'autre moyen de faire
c'est ça le problème
donc aujourd'hui le travail des
gouvernants le trail des politiques
c'est de prévoir des dispositifs des
procédures des plans pour qu'on est vide
mains d'avoir à mettre le pays à l'arrêt
parce que nous ne le supporteront pas 11
% de chute de pipe c'est quelque chose
enfin probablement c'est quelque chose
d'une parquet supérieur ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays
puis la reprise est lente la reprise et
hardy certains disent on a peut-être
confiné trop tard et on a peut-être des
consignes et trop tard aussi votre avis
aussi dans une question qu'on peut se
poser et que la commission denquête
laquelle la commission d' enquête devra
répondre c'est à sac et le cerf cette
commission denquête c'est à répondre à
ce type de question pourquoi est ce que
nous nous sommes trouvés à ce point
désarmé démunis pour faire face à cette
pandémie et avec toute la cohorte
problèmes économiques et sociaux qui en
résulte voilà c'est la question qu'on
peut se poser
mais une fois que c'était l'art est ce
que vous allez commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale il y en aura de
une à l'assemblée nationale une au sénat
ce que vous pensez que la commission de
l'assemblée nationale va aboutir à ces
conclusions
va faire son travail ou est ce que ça va
aboutir à un benalla bis puis c'est
l'expression que celle employée
si ça devait aboutir à un benalla bis
ce serait absolument dramatique mais je
pense que le gouvernement et la majorité
ne s'y risquera pas je crois qu'il faut
affronter la vérité avec courage et de
façon transparente c'est la seule façon
mon avis d'aborder les choses pour le
gouvernement
faute de quoi ils perdraient absolument
tout crédit auprès des français est au
bout j'aurais été à l'assemblée est
prête à ce travail si elle ne l'est pas
ce sera vraiment dramatique non
seulement pour elle même et pour la
parole politique qui perdrait ainsi
toute crédibilité
donc je fais confiance à eric ciotti
qu'il va être le rapporteur général et à
damien abad qui sera le vice-président
de cette commission d' enquête pour
établir la vérité des faits qui est
indispensable pourquoi avons-nous été
obligé de confiner aussi violemment
pourquoi avons nous manqué de tout pour
protéger les français
pourquoi nous sommes nous retrouver dans
une situation plus difficile que
d'autres pays européens
ce sont ces réponses que nous attendons
que les français attendent justement ma
part les questions de santé travail est
question de santé de moyen de méthodes
d'organisation
les personnels soignants une partie des
personnels soignants sont appelés à se
mobiliser le 16 juin prochain
justement pour une revalorisation de
leurs conditions de travail et puis de
l'organisation vous soutiendrez ce
mouvement vous savez c'est cette crise a
révélé beaucoup de choses
on n'a pas fini d'en tirer les
enseignements mais elle a révélé une
chose qui a été exprimé par dans un très
beau papier de chantal delsol dans un
quotidien
récemment où elle a parlé des métiers de
la tension les métiers de l'attention
que par exemple les métiers des
soignants et au fond elle dit cette
crise elle a révélé toute l'importance
des métiers de la tension par rapport
aux métiers de la production et je
trouvais que c'était intéressant cette
notion des métiers de la tension il est
clair que les soignants ils ont été
admirables admirable parce qu ils sont
courus des risques qu'ils ont pris des
risques pour nous ils l'ont fait aux
limites de leurs forces ils ont
travaillé comme des forcenés pour pour
nous soigner et dans les rites
oui c'est le moment ces immenses et 11
ans d'errements c'est le moment où il
faut mettre et là ils ont raison la
revalorisation les dernière
revalorisation de ses métiers
c'est nicolas sarkozy et qui a dit
fiscalisation des heures supplémentaires
et c'est avec la requalification par
exemple des métiers d'infirmier qui ont
qui sont passés dans une catégorie
supérieure qu'ils ont raison de
manifester à ce moment là il ya un
travail qui engageait le ségur de la
santé pour une réforme de l'hôpital pour
des revalorisations comprend qu'il odile
a dit edouard philippe s est ce qu'il
faut attendre les conclusions d'une
figure de la santé où est ce qu'ils ont
raison de manifester dès le 16 juin
c'est une piqûre de rappel si j'ose dire
compte tenu de leur métier pour dire
le chèque vacances que vous nous
proposez vous avez vu ce texte qui était
proposée par la majorité de permettre de
le don de chèques-vacances ses bases au
projet de conforma blanc chèques
vacances voilà le les soignants ont dit
ça ne suffit pas ça ne suffit pas mais
revalorisation significative a dit
edwards filet oui revêt la dotation
significative ça veut dire ça veut dire
que sans tarder il faut effectivement
faire des propositions alors ça signifie
aussi qu'il faut revoir un certain
nombre de choses à l'hôpital et
notamment la sueur administration de
l'hôpital qui est devenue folle qu'il ya
un emballement administratif à l'hôpital
quand vous interrogez les soignants et
ça fait plusieurs années moi quand
j'étais maire qui présidait un conseil
d'administration puis un conseil de
surveillance
c'était déjà un mouvement qui étaient à
l'oeuvre les procédures administratives
sont démentes à l'hôpital les soignants
passe plus de temps à remplir des
dossiers parfois qu'à être au pied du
lit des malades il l'a dit d'ailleurs on
a enfin pendant la crise sanitaire
on est revenu à notre métier qui est le
soin donc là il ya des marges de
manoeuvre financières je pense à trouver
pour pouvoir revaloriser les salaires
des soignants françois hollande a
reconnu sa part de responsabilité dans
la situation actuelle de l'hôpital est
ce que la droite a aussi la sienne dès
lors que vous êtes aux manettes vous
avez une responsabilité il faut pas s'y
dérober
cela étant et je pense d'ailleurs que
dans le plan santé patients territoires
le plan hpst hôpital santé patients
territoires qui avaient été conduits par
agnès buzyn notamment la rémunération à
l'acte notamment c'est eux c'est ce
mouvement de sur l'administration de
l'hôpital a été enclenchée à ce moment
là il faut en tirer les enseignements
moi je trouve de fait sur la
responsabilité de la droite est ce qu'à
une volonté de faire trop d'économies
sur le dos de l'hôpital non ce qui a mis
à genoux l'hôpital c'est
la réforme des 35 heures une réforme des
35 heures mal pensée se dire que car
coup d'un seul
on a privé l'hôpital de
dix pour cent de sa de de sa masse de
ses salariés soit commencée alors n'a
pas compensé ça veut dire la faune
recevoir le temps de travail alors c'est
vrai que cette réforme dès 14 ans et que
cheval de bataille de la droite
ça veut dire que ces 35 inconsidérément
appliqué à l'hôpital ont commencé à
porter des coups très sévères à l
équilibre du travail à l'hôpital
donc on peut toujours refaire l'histoire
maintenant il faut tirer les
enseignements de tout ça mais surtout il
faut prendre des mesures
parce que on ne pourra pas on ne pourra
pas indéfiniment imposé à l'hôpital le
rythme de travail qui est le sien dans
les conditions qui sont les siennes
il faut des revalorisations salariales
il faut une réorganisation du travail
il faut une débureaucratisation
l'hôpital il ya beaucoup de choses à
travailler
un mot sur un sujet dont vous occuper
c'est l'éducation est ce qu'il faut
maintenant assouplir le protocole dans
les écoles où tu es hier soir j'étais en
conférence avec le préfet mon préfet
comme plusieurs fois par semaine comme
tous les parlementaires depuis le début
de cette crise
et hier nous avons parlé comme nous le
faisons depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines de la reprise scolaire
c'est dramatique moi je me fais beaucoup
de souci parce que au fond il ya des
enfants qui n'ont pas fréquenté l'école
depuis mars et qui ne la fréquenteront
pas avant septembre
dans le meilleur des cas dans le
meilleur des cas parce que l'inspecteur
d'académie hier soir disait je ne sais
pas dans quelles conditions de prêts par
an la rentrée si on mattia l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
je ne sais pas si tous les élèves
pourront revenir à l'école ça veut dire
9 - sans école et peut-être davantage
c'est dans une vie d'écoliers dans une
vie de collégien blessé à une perte
considérable dont on a un film ou
d'ailleurs est d'ailleurs le premier
ministre lui même en le regrettant
ensuite à parler de bombes à retardement
mais il a raison c'est le terme qui
convient c'est une bombe à retardement
si on assouplit pas le protocole si les
élèves ne peuvent pas revenir à l'école
c'est absolument dramatique même à
quinze jours trois semaines de voir
moins pour certains dont on parle mon
tour un retour autour du 20 au 22 juin
à quelques jours de la sortie des
classes
je pense que psychologiquement c'est un
psycho logiquement scolairement
psychologiquement c'est important trois
semaines d'école ces trois semaines
d'école c'est toujours ça de pris si
j'ose dire ça ne compensera pas
absolument pas le manque même si dans
certains cas les enseignants ont fait
d'énormes efforts les beaucoup de
familles ont accompagné ses efforts mais
pas partout il ya jusqu'à 50% de
décrocheurs dans certains établissements
scolaires
vous imaginez et ça veut dire 50%
notamment dans les lycées techniques qui
sont devenus invisibles aux deux par
l'institution scolaire
c'est dramatique moi je pense que c'est
un des aspects les plus terribles du
confinement
autre sujet d'actualité brûlant les
violences policières des mobilisations
manifestation à lille encore hier
une activité qui nous vient des états
unis mais aussi une actualité française
vous entendez cette colère cette
mobilisation contre les violences
policières
alors je pense que il ya une
concomitance terrible entre le rendu de
l'expertisé concernant la sphère adama
traoré et l'assassinât de floyd aux
états unis cette concomitance des faits
produits les événements que nous avons
vu avant-hier à paris hier soir à lille
dire qu'il ya une lecture de la sphère
adama traoré qui se fait à travers c'est
abominable assassinat de floyd aux états
unis et je crois que ça n'a rien à voir
ça n'a rien à voir et je récuse les
termes utilisés par la tribune d'omar sy
aujourd'hui qui parle d'un système de
violences policières
je trouve que c'est faire injure à la
police française que de considérer qu'il
ya un racisme d'état qui a un racisme
policiers il y à une exigence de
comportements vertueux dans la police
qui est le corps le plus contrôlé de
france je veux dire les policiers qui
interviennent aujourd'hui ils sont
filmés
les films sont diffusés sur les réseaux
sociaux
ils font l'objet d' enquête
administrative ils peuvent être
condamnés
donc c'est un corps extrêmement
contrôlée je ne peux pas dire qu'il n'y
a eu jamais d'agissements délictueux ou
qu'il n'y en aura jamais parce que les
hommes sont les hommes mais je pense que
c'est pour ça que le terme même de
violence policière me choque parce que
ça voudrait dire qu'il ya une
institutionnalisation de la violence au
sein de la police que je récuse
nous avons une police courageuse nous
avons une police vertueuse si des actes
délictueux sont comme ils doivent être
poursuivis mais il n'y a pas de système
raciste de violence police et les années
de l'hermine et des individus
qui pose problème on va parler des
municipales lisbonne 29
il nous reste peu de temps à corps entre
la république en marche et les
républicains dans plusieurs villes de
france pour le second tour comment on
peut vouloir incarner l'alternance et
s'allier avec le parti présidentiel
n'ont alors je vous arrête tout de suite
il n'y a pas d'alliance avec le parti
présidentiel
tout d'abord il ya des listes communes
dans plusieurs villes de france alors il
y a tout d'abord au premier tour 56 %
des communes françaises soutenues ou
investie par les républicains qui ont
été réélus donc ça veut dire d'ores et
déjà les républicains sont dans une
situation de victoire de ces municipales
mais sur ses alliés dans son run it
commune dans une poignée de communes et
on va en reparler
qu'ils soient des covenants hautement
stratégique qui sent des communes
hautement stratégique mais à paris pas
d'alliance à marseille
pas d'alliance prenons l'exemple de
bordeaux qui est un exemple intéressant
à bordeaux là le maire sortant heller à
jour de cotisation sera je l'espère
réélu il a bénéficié du soutien du
candidat de la république en marche mais
le programme qui sera appliquée sera le
programme du candidat
les républicains la majorité absolue
sera une majorité dirigée par le maire
les républicains s'il gagne donc et
et prenons l'exemple de strasbourg par
exemple est-ce que strasbourg vous êtes
derrière liste étiquetée la république
en marche est ce que vous ne risquez pas
d'offrir la victoire à la république en
marche une peut-être de ses seules
victoires d'ailleurs dans une grande
ville alors je voudrais dire que d'abord
à strasbourg candidat n'a rien demandé
il faut bien considérer que les
municipales moi qui étais mer pendant 15
ans et il y a une configuration qui est
toujours le cas lie à un pragmatisme
locale qui fait qu' on peut être amené
quand on est candidat aux municipales à
s'allier avec des candidats des
conseillers des futurs conseillers qui
ne sont pas qu'ils ne partagent pas
forcément vos opinions politiques ça
arrive tout le temps on va pas demander
son certificat de pureté politique à un
camp à un colistier qu'on veut amener à
soi parce que c'est un responsable
associatif
parce que c'est un commerçant en vue
parce que c'est une personnalité et mes
dans la ville bon voilà donc justement
est ce qu'il n'aurait pas mieux valu
mieux pour vous perdre quelques villes
plutôt que de brouiller le message je
vous accorde que la confusion elle est
périlleuse et elle est compliquée à
gérer
vous les regrettés ca maintenant
maintenant
il faut veiller à ce que ces accords qui
encore une fois sont très peu nombreux
sont ponctuels et n'ont pas été traités
et non pas été fait avec la bénédiction
de dieu nationale par les logiques
nationales c'est ce cas il n'y a pas de
logique nationale et même si ce sont des
communes importantes
veillons à ne pas donner une lecture
nationale à des accords locaux qu'ils
doivent demeurer le coup merci beaucoup
merci a déjà l'air d'avoir été avec no
mercy fabrique